so the standard model physics is one of
the models that's very accurate for
describing three
three of the fundamental forces of
physics and it's looking at the
the world of the very small right and
then there's back to the
neighbor of uh gravity or general
relativity
so and in the context of a theory of
everything
what's traditionally the task
of the unification of these theories
the issue is you try to use the methods
of quantum field theory
to talk about gravity and it doesn't
work just like there are photons of
light
so there are gravitons which are sort of
the particles of gravity and when you
try and compute
sort of the properties of the of the
particles of gravity
the kind of mathematical tricks that get
used um
in working things out in quantum field
theory don't work
and um that's um so that's been a sort
of fundamental issue
and when you think about black holes
which are a place where
uh sort of the the the structure of
space is um
uh you know has has sort of rapid
variation and you get kind of quantum
effects mixed in
with effects from general relativity
things get very complicated and there
are apparent paradoxes and things like
that
and people have you know that been a
bunch of mathematical developments
in in physics over the last i don't know
30 years or so
which have kind of picked away at those
kinds of issues
and got hints about how things might
work um
and but it hasn't been uh you know the
other thing to realize is
as far as physics is concerned it's just
like his general relativity
his quantum field theory you know be
happy yeah i said do you think there's a
quantization of gravity quantum gravity
what do you think of efforts that people
have tried to
yeah what do you think in general of the
efforts of the physics community to try
to unify these
laws so i think what's it's interesting
i mean i would have said something very
different
before what's happened with our physics
project um
i mean you know the remarkable thing is
what we've
been able to do is to make from this
very
simple structurally simple underlying
set of ideas we've been able to build
this this
you know very elaborate structure that's
both very abstract
and very sort of mathematically rich and
the big surprise as far as i'm concerned
is that it touches many of the ideas
that people have had
so in other words things like string
theory and so on uh twister theory
it's like the you know we might have
thought i had thought
we're out on a prong we're building
something that's computational it's
completely different from what other
people have done
but actually it seems like what we've
done is to provide essentially the
machine code
that you know these things are of
various features of domain-specific
languages so to speak
that talk about various aspects of this
machine code and i think there's a
this is something that to me is is is
very exciting because it allows one
both for us to provide sort of a new
foundation for what's been thought about
there
and for the all the work that's been
done in those areas
to you know to give us you know more
more momentum
to be able to figure out what's going on
now you know people have sort of hoped
oh we're just going to be able to get
you know string theory to just answer
everything that hasn't worked out
and i think we now kind of can see a
little bit about just sort of how far
away certain kinds of things are from
being able to explain things
some things one of the big surprises to
me actually i literally just
got a message about one aspect of this
is um
uh the uh uh you know it's turning out
to be easier i mean
this project has been so much easier
than i could ever imagine it would be
that is
i thought we would be you know just
about able to understand the first 10
minus 100 seconds of the universe and um
you know it would be 100 years before we
get much further than that
it's just turned out it actually wasn't
that hard i mean we're not finished but
you know you're you're seeing echoes of
all the disparate
theories of physics in this framework
yes yes i mean it's a very interesting
you know sort of history of science like
phenomenon i mean
the best analogy that i can see is what
happened with the early
early days of of computability and
computation theory
you know turing machines were invented
in 1936.
people sort of understand computation in
terms of turing machines but actually
there had been pre-existing theories of
computation combinators
general recursive functions lambda
calculus things like this
but people hadn't those hadn't been
concrete enough
that people could really wrap their arms
around them and understand what was
going on
and i think what we're going to see in
this case is that a bunch of these
mathematical theories
including some very i mean one of the
things that's really interesting is
one of the most abstract things that's
come out of of sort of
uh mathematics higher category theory
things about
infinity groupoids things like this
which to me always just seemed like they
were floating off into the
stratosphere ionosphere of mathematics
um turn out to be things which our
sort of theory anchors down to something
fairly definite and
says are super relevant to the way that
we can understand how physics works
you